. One of the real problems we've seen under
the current administration is the weaponization
of propaganda to a degree that we didn't see
under Barack Obama, we didn't see under George
W. Bush, we didn't see under Bill Clinton,
we didn't see under George H.W. Bush administrations.
It doesn't mean those administrations didn't
propagandize to some degree, doesn't mean
they didn't do bad things.
But it is a level that we have never seen
before under Donald Trump and a very reliable
propaganda tool.
Whenever Donald Trump fails, whenever Donald
Trump embarrasses the country, whenever Trump's
actions lead to suffering or to death or to
plunder or whatever it is, is to go back to
revert to fake news, lamestream media.
OK.
That's the technique at any time.
It's like a get out of jail free card for
Donald Trump whenever he fails us once again,
which is almost daily under the umbrella of
the virus.
The focus becomes lake lamestream media, fake
news.
OK, he's failed on the prevention.
Well, it's a fake news.
He's lying about it.
He's failed on the suppression.
The lamestream media is not being fair to
him.
He's failing on mitigation of governors are
lying about how many ventilators they need.
He's failing on science.
He's failing on common sense.
And so Donald Trump has shifted almost exclusively
to attacking media coverage of his handling
of the Corona virus pandemic rather than actually
dealing with the caseload and the death toll
and everything that's going on.
Trump tweeting, quote, Because the ratings
of my news conferences are so high.
Bachelor finale, Monday Night Football type
numbers.
According to The New York Times, the lame
stream media is going crazy.
Trump is reaching too many people.
We must stop him, said one lunatic.
See you at 5:00 p.m. Trump, referring to his
press conference yesterday, then going on
to tweet again about the ratings of his press
conferences.
And remember, at the press conferences, he
barely talks about the virus itself.
He focuses on self-congratulation.
And that, according to The New York Times,
he says President Trump is a ratings hit.
Since reviving the daily White House briefing,
Mr. Trump and his Corona virus updates have
attracted an average audience of eight point
five million on cable news.
Roughly the viewership of the season finale
of The Bachelor.
Numbers are continuing to rise on Monday.
Nearly twelve point two million people watched
the briefing Monday Night Football numbers.
Millions are watching on ABC, CBS, NBC and
online streaming.
And the audience is expanding.
On Monday, Fox News alone attracted six million
viewers, an astounding number for 6 p.m. cable
broadcasts, more akin to the viewership for
a popular primetime sitcom.
The CBS News poll said 13 percent of Republicans
trusted the news media for information about
the virus.
He's comparing press briefings to The Bachelor.
He's comparing press briefings about a virus
that is leading to people dropping dead more
every day to a reality show.
And what he fails to understand, because it's
it's too difficult, I guess, for him to understand
anything but the most simplistic analysis.
People aren't watching like they watched The
Bachelor.
People don't watch your press briefings for
entertainment.
They're watching because more and more people
are getting sick.
More and more people are dying and people
are scared.
They're at home increasingly, which is good.
And they find out the president is going to
talk about what is going on.
And they want to see something reassuring.
They want to hear something that would be
akin to I understand the difficulty and this
is a tragedy and we're losing good people.
But here's what.
Instead, Trump is talking about the popularity
of the briefings and in the briefings congratulating
himself, attacks journalists endlessly.
Here's Trump talking about his ratings during
yesterday's press briefing.
The American public ultimately that they should
be the decider.
It's like if they don't want to watch, they
shouldn't watch.
And we shouldn't have bigger ratings than
The Bachelor or as The New York Times said,
we have.
Monday Night Football type ratings.
No, I didn't say that I have no idea what
they are.
In a sense.
But I know that the times they say it's all
the news that's fit to print.
I say it's all the news.
It's not fit to print.
Because I think they are not honest people.
But that's OK.
But they can't help it.
But even they said that the ratings are like
Monday night football ratings and that these
are like bachelor finale that's there.
And when the big deal happened, I have no
idea what happened because I'm too busy working
on there's someday you will tell me what happened.
People are dying.
And Trump is tweeting and talking about his
ratings for when he actually is failing to
deal with the issue.
Instead, attacking media and talking about
the the fact that people watch the press conferences
and of course, constantly saying nobody's
giving me credit.
Nobody's giving me credit.
Meanwhile, the bodies are literally piling
up.
Here's an image of a truck and an ambulance
bay at a New York hospital yesterday taken
by a nurse.
The bodies literally piling up.
It's truly sick and it's sociopathic.
And, Wolf, that word will come up again when
we hear from Dr. Justin Frank.
A little bit later today, he's the grim reaper
of ratings, so to speak.
The more people die, the more people watch.
He's his briefings and he interprets that
as satisfaction with the briefings, as the
fact that the briefings are entertaining.
And, of course, ignores the reality that more
and more people are watching because more
and more people are home and scared with each
passing day.
The American public is more and more concerned
with the fiasco that has become our government's
response to this pandemic.
That's why people are watching to try to figure
out is there anything on the horizon that
might help this?
And when they tune in and they see Trump talk
attacking journalists, saying, don't be a
cutey pie, that's an ask the question, et
cetera.
People are disgusted.
They're not watching like they watch The Bachelor.
But that's all Trump seems to care about.